il s'agit d'une première pour un
président de l'époque post-apartheid en
afrique du sud après avoir joué au chat
et à la souris avec la justice jacob
zuma au pouvoir entre 2009 et 2010 8 a
été incarcéré durant la nuit dans une
prison de l'est du pays il est arrivé
juste après une heure du matin
vous savez qu'en tant qu'ancien
président il a une unité de protection
présidentielle
ils nous l'ont amené mais maintenant
nous devons prendre le relais et je dois
m'assurer qu'il est incarcéré en toute
sécurité et nous devons également
répondre à ces besoins spéciaux s'ils
ont été identifiées et mises en cause
dans une quarantaine de témoignages est
condamné à quinze mois de réclusion pour
outrage après avoir refusé de témoigner
devant une commission anti corruption et
jacob zuma a multiplié les recours en
justice pour éviter de passer par la
case prison et malgré une première nuit
en cellule il porte encore l'espoir
d'une révision de sa sentence
une nouvelle audience aura lieu en ce
sens le 12 juillet alors qu'il a déjà
passé une décennie derrière les barreaux
aux côtés de nelson mandela
l'homme âgé de 79 ans est dépeint comme
étant capable du meilleur comme du pire
a déclaré il ya quelques jours ne pas
être effrayé à l'idée de retourner en
prison
à nantes stade je n'ai pas peur d'aller
en prison pour mes convictions je ne
demande pas la sympathie former la
justice mon âge mon état de santé
elle est née à da et toute autre
circonstance atténuante n'ont pas été
prises en compte
well note concéda figure de la lutte
anti-apartheid ce combattant pour la
liberté conserve une cote de popularité
non négligeable dans son pays
mais ces neuf années au pouvoir marqués
par une succession de scandales se sont
terminées par une démission devenue
inévitable et pour l'analyste politique
sud-africain howard feldman le fait que
jacob zuma se soit rendu à la justice
est un symbole fort pour cette toute
jeune démocratie
c'est une victoire énorme
soyons clairs vous le savez peut-être il
ne s'agit pas de son procès pour
corruption les d'une condamnation pour
outrage au tribunal
car il refusait de comparaître dans le
cadre de l' enquête pour corruption
il a manqué de respect aux tribunaux et
la plus haute juridiction du pays l'a
déclaré coupable il ne s'agit pas de
corruption
ce procès reste à venir mais c'est un
symbole de l'indépendance du judiciaire
en afrique du sud qu'il ne peut pas être
influencé par la politique et qui peut
faire mettre en prison quelqu'un pour
son crime
c'est un message très important pour le
gouvernement actuel et pour le peuple
sud africain
c'est un moment majeur dans l'histoire
de l'afrique du sud jacob zuma a mené le
pays au bord du gouffre à de nombreuses
reprises
c'était le cas ici la situation aurait
pu basculer à tout moment et la
population était très inquiète de ce qui
allait arriver
le fait que cela finisse avec jacob zuma
en prison en dit long sur la justice de
ce pays c'est un jour très important